hi my name is Josh varsity prom from the
surgeon and I'm the chief executive
officer for International Development
Corporation the investment promotion arm
of messaging and I'm commenting on what
was said by fab on facebook I what I
need to make vocational training a
priority navarrete I believe that
Africa's future lies in human capital
investment in capital development so yes
if we invest in building skills involved
invest in youth that will unleash the
potential for entrepreneurship and that
will ensure that all the youth of Africa
do not have to queue for government jobs
but can actually create jobs that will
also share them polycom